the illegal use of marijuana is the
latest temptation available to tens of
millions of people who visit Las Vegas
each year Nevada last month became the
eighth state to allow the sale of
recreational pot to adults 21 and over
but even as Las Vegas restricts what
people can do after they legally buy
their pot mark Strassmann is on the
strip with what's once say is
discrepancies in the law mark good
morning good morning this is the essence
cannabis dispensary which sells 50
different strains of legal marijuana
this brand is called venom OG a gram of
a cost $18 cash only
but for tourists the legal challenge
starts as soon as you walk out the front
door anything goes in Vegas right wrong
on the strip buying marijuana legally is
one thing smoking it is another Nevada
law mandates that legally bought
marijuana be consumed in a private
residence nothing public which includes
casinos hotels cars and sidewalks are
monuments who owns dispensary says the
law puts most of his customers in a
tough spot about 70 to 80 percent of
tourists and these people have no
private space to go to because they
deliver what's the problem no other
industry in the world can you buy a
product and then not use it anywhere
it's silly in the eight states that have
legalized marijuana implementing the new
drug laws has been challenging for
consumers for instance people in
California and Massachusetts may possess
it or grow it but not buyer-seller
legally until next year sales are legal
in Colorado Nevada and Washington but
for now public consumption is banned
state senator tix Sager Blum supported
legalizing marijuana here people are
already buying it people are using it so
this is not something new it's just
let's go ahead and take the next step
and acknowledge that fact and provide a
venue for them where they can have fun
marijuana has a place in Sin City
marijuana is perfect for Sin City but
for now Vegas casinos and hotels have
too much at stake to allowance
Gaming is a thirteen billion dollar a
year business in this state casino
licenses require following federal state
and local laws this is the marijuana
industry this is the gaming industry and
the two shall never meet Tony Alamo
shares the Nevada Gaming Commission but
at the end of the day it's very
clear-cut it's against federal law and
until the federal law changes that's the
standard they have to maintain 25 year
old David Harper is visiting from
Houston the marijuana he bought legally
he'll smoked illegally disagree there is
no consensus about the solution here the
local marijuana industry is pushing to
legalize pot cafes that kind of have
overseas in Amsterdam and the kind that
Colorado will roll out later this month
but for now Margaret what tourists buy
in Vegas they can't use in Vegas thank
you